[Musique]
qu'as-tu fait à mon estomac,
nous avons simplement glissé un paquet et ton
bas-ventre et tu vas nous
transporter quelque chose de très spécial,
on estime que la plupart des êtres Dylan
n'utilisent que 10% de la capacité du cerveau, imaginez
si nous  pourrait accéder à plus de notre
capacité cérébrale toujours pensé que l'esprit humain
est comme n'importe quel autre muscle si
nous lui demandions d'en faire plus,
il répondrait probablement à ses propres
attentes il y a certains médicaments
qui peuvent ouvrir le cerveau et rendre la
personne beaucoup  plus susceptible d'apprendre et d'
apprendre plus vite bientôt oui professeur Norman
je m'appelle Lucy je viens de lire toutes vos
recherches sur le cerveau humain
mais vous êtes sur mon essai merci nous
n'utilisons pas la
capacité maximale possible depuis quand avez-vous
commencer à écrire le chinois il n'y a pas longtemps il y a
des scientifiques qui croient que notre
capacité est infinie je peux sentir chaque
chose vivante je dirais les
possibilités infinies et la raison pour laquelle je
dis que c'est il y a cent ans nous
ne pouvions  dicté ce que vous avez aujourd'hui
donc tout ce que je prédis aujourd'hui sera presque
certainement faux dans 30 40 50
ans non ce n'est pas
possible c'est une voiture de police tout ce que nous savons
sur le cerveau pourrait être faux nous avons
codifié notre existence pour faire  c'est
compréhensible pour que nous puissions oublier son
échelle insondable questionner des choses
sur la capacité du cerveau et où il
peut aller ce qui se passe quand elle atteint 100
pour cent je n'ai aucune idée de
vous